have a confusion going on we see him
praying salah one more minute and he
as far as he just claimed to be a muslim
etc um
but in these videos there are statements
of disbelief god
the god of ganja is here he's thinking
okay i didn't hear that right so he
asked him a question saying
what do you mean you see god look at
what tyson says
he corrects him you
are him okay so you're equal to him
i'm not you're not you or him
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro is picky to the nighties
moschino and versace no laces in
cheese new millennium assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing shadow welcome
back to this video
now i came across an interesting video
with matt tyson
he was in paul logan's logan paul with
his
uh his show yeah um and um
a few months ago there was a video where
mike tyson was praying salah
um praying salah with a few brothers in
the gym
now this kind of shocked me because the
statements that i've been made are like
how could i say like if somebody said if
mike tyson came and said
uh what he said about there like if he
said you know what i um i won't have
intercourse with my own mom
what he said is one billion trillion
quadrillion times worse than that
and this is only understood for those
who understand what tawhid and [ __ ] kids
if you don't understand that these words
are just going to be like okay it's not
a big deal it's not a big deal yeah
let's watch it uh and let's analyze
because there's a bit of a confusion
going on
we see him praying salah one more minute
and he as far as he just claimed to be a
muslim et cetera um
but in these videos they're statements
of this belief made now i'm not saying
it's a disbeliever i need to be very
careful here
um he could be most like maybe fallen
into the
area of ignorance in the context of he
doesn't know so please
hold back instead of saying he's a
catholic i said please this is not your
uh place this matters of scholars
because then they
there might be a lot of factors in place
which we need to take out yeah islam
is run by you know the scholars are
there for a reason we're not here to do
that yeah and that's one of the things
i object to us youngsters or youtubers
coming out and doing stuff like that
calling people innovators
uh these guys i'm up teddy uh this guy's
a cafe etc
so let's abstain from that let's learn
from this inshallah and finish with the
quran
this video is with some rastafarians yes
let's see what he says i watch you
sometimes that's for mike tyson right
there baby
dungeon god the god of ganja is here at
the roster camp
the god of gandra is here now that could
be used as an
expression of you know uh
if people say you know this is the mecca
of
or this is the i would be the god of
this is the to show yeah
he he's the best not literally meaning
it's an expression used but it's still
so
dangerous man it's still so dangerous
as a muslim um these words
are so dangerous but let's carry on here
yeah
so here you can see my titan's hands are
in there there's some kind of ritual
going on someone told me that
they're calling out to their ancestors
or something along those lines
and mata's got his hands he's not seeing
anything but
again dangerous lines dangerous lines
now with the paul logan video that we're
going to watch it gets a little bit more
disturbing let's let's let's watch for
ourselves inshallah and let's
come to a conclusion let's let's
understand okay here we go everything
was different you wouldn't want to
at least experience that one two times
before you passed
listen um let's go deeper that you might
experience being god for a few minutes
that's what it does introduce you to god
what do you think one on one basis
that's what people say georgie
i'm listening i'm not encouraging
obviously as a person in my standing i
have to actually i mean
it didn't go so well the toad
what do you mean when you see god like
you have a legit like you see him or
you're equal to him
so here this guy is a christian he's a
staunch christian so he's
he's he's thinking okay i didn't hear
that right so he asked him a question
saying
what do you mean you see god look how
matt tyson says
he corrects him you are him
okay so you're equal to him i'm not
you're not you want him
got it i don't think george is going to
like that he's a very
nice he's a christian very big christian
no no this is bigger than religion right
so one of this people there on the show
he's saying look george is not going to
like that he's a staunch christian now
as a christian man he finds this guy
finds it difficult to fathom that he was
like
and they believe that we believe they
they involved in some
paganism in the context you know you're
you're associate importance to god
and as a christian who believes jesus is
god incarnate
he's even taken a bit back with mike
tyson's statement saying that
you know he he's saying i i'm not equal
i i'm saying
he got my says i'm saying i became god
or something was nice i experienced it
this is um and also i don't this is this
is dying
this is dying this is letting you know
this stuff you see your ancestors
you want to meet some answers you want
to meet people who died recently you
love
handle with the toad it takes you way
back buddy
so he's talking about some kind of drugs
yeah or some kind of
i don't know what it is here that he
takes and he causes this and this is why
it's so dangerous for themselves that's
why
islam is forbidden for you to take
intoxicants in any sort
because it takes you to another realm
and we believe in the unseen we believe
in the jinn
and shaytan etc we believe in these
things so when you are open to a
different realm
that's why it's it's it's madness
because when it comes to doing
magic when you involve this stuff when
you see that stuff it's done
you're finished why in the corner
because you've reached the kind of
pinnacle of
disbelief because now the test is done
you've seen things
that nobody should see to see with sir
and a few other stuff
so now you're just a full out this
believer and i'm not saying him i'm
talking about in general
so you can see what drugs are doing to
him
be it weed or whatever except that the
substance abuse
has brought him to a point where he's
claiming to be good
now pharaoh pharaoh claimed to be god as
well
now he did it out of arrogance fully
knowing
that he is wrong he did it out of
arrogance here
mike tyson seems like he doesn't know
what he's saying
like he doesn't understand he doesn't
fathom if he's a muslim he doesn't
um when i'm saying like he's a muslim
but he doesn't understand father what
he's saying
he genuinely doesn't understand um and
and
you can see that the ignorance the
exclusive ignorance can be given let's
carry on
this is scary i'm not sure
i want that smoke is there any i don't
know if i can handle it is there any uh
like god forbid like oh if you do like a
tiny bit too much
you can't die from it oh okay so it's
just a for sure experience
and if you look at medically it takes
people off of drugs stop people from
being
schizophrenic depressed still that's it
yeah the snake does that as well so does
you can't die and might have to say that
it takes people have been schizophrenic
and
being depressed etc well the thing is if
you take that drug and that drug is
telling you
that you are god and all these kind of
statements well he hasn't killed your
body
but he's definitely slaughtered your
soul and he's literally
and that drug or whatever it is that
you're encountering he's butchered your
soul
he's literally butchered he doesn't care
if your body is dead or not he doesn't
care because
he believes shaytan wants your soul you
need to understand brother sisters if he
doesn't care if he kills your body
that's one body gone okay
and we're going to die he has butchered
your soul broth
he's ma and if my testosterone if you're
watching this please
just understand what i'm about to say uh
and please with an open mind
yeah i'm here to have a go at you i'm
here to make you understand the
statements that you're uttering as a
muslim
they are the pinnacle of this belief and
they are the
pinnacle of ingratitude you know and
let's just finish and i'm gonna
elaborate
told the snake the lizard the centipede
you mentioned this experience feeling
like your your soul leaves your body
my soul did leave my body so i have a
question because you you're pretty well
versed with psychedelics
what is uh the soul excuse me the soul
what is it what if you had to describe
it what is so here they just drove into
um basically what the soul is and mike
tyson talks about
a few other stuff that's irrelevant to
our point brother and sisters right
right now the reason i'm doing this
video is because firstly we need to
understand something just because we see
a really popular person praying saying
alhamdulillah saying mashaallah yes
it's good to hear but sometimes we need
to understand
that we shouldn't ultimately put our
full trust
in them blindly because what happens is
like a few months ago he was praying
salah that is good but we would highly
encourage brother mike tyson
to study islam to study because
it seems as if he's a muslim and this
could be variety of righteous reasons it
could be the fact that you know
he was influenced by muhammad ali and et
cetera and he just wanted to be a
part of the clique where we don't know
we assume the best part like we don't
know maybe or maybe he's genuine he is
searching
but he's mixed with the wrong crowd and
mixing with the wrong crowd this is what
it does to you brown sisters like the
prophet peace be upon him said
if a good friend is like someone like
who sells musk
when you're around him even if you don't
benefit from anything you're going to
leave smelling good
and if you have a bad friend a bad
friend is like a blacksmith
even if he doesn't give you any harm
you're going to leave with smoke and
smelling bad
and this is what happens with my sisters
now like i said before i'm not doing
clear of him i'm not saying but his
statements are statements of kuffar
yeah it stands for coffee you might see
someone bowing down to a tree and
soprano you can say okay the act itself
is kufar yes
does that person do intentionally or not
that's how this discussion scholars
we have scholars for but one i it's so
sad you know because i didn't date allah
is the one who's given us everything man
and one night sometimes before i came to
islam i said to myself okay
i look i know what [ __ ] i kind of know
what tahiti is and i was thinking
what's so hard i don't understand why is
it so difficult for people to worship
allah alone
you alone we worship and you alone will
ask for help what is
so damn hard i don't understand is it so
hard to acknowledge that allah has given
you blessings allah has created you
there's a purpose
the way you're created the way you
design everything
is it so hard to worship him alone
and then i understood you know what
subhanallah
subhanallah worship is not just bound
down to a tree
we understood i understood it's not
bound down to a tree people worship
money
people worship the opposite gender they
literally worship opposite gender
that's what they do and that's what
allah says in the quran have you seen
the one who takes himself as his illah
as his desires as his own god
so apparently all the statements have
been uttered i became god i would
be like so brother mike tyson if you're
watching this please understand
that what your steps uttering blessing
me you're claiming yourself to be good
and we know it contradicts that because
you say you know like your body leaves
the soul etc like that
you're mortal you can you can never be
good no one can be good
and the stainless through the archery
are so dangerous
stay away from these kind of friends you
know
and we just ask allah to guide us and
guide you
and please study the religion inshallah
and so you can understand what is
tawheed
you know and to show your gratitude to
god and serve him the way he deserves to
be and i'm going to end with the verse
in the quran and surah al-anam
because it's a beautiful verse
alhamdulillah it says
brothers and sisters um and yes i'm
going to end with that verse inshallah
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
all praises is for allah who created the
heavens and the earth
and made darkness and light yet the
disbeliever set up equals to their lord
in worship
he is the one who created you from clay
then appointed a term for your death
and another known for only and another
known only to him
for your resurrection and yet you
continue to doubt
he is the only true god in the heavens
and the earth he knows whatever you
conceal
and whatever you reveal and knows
whatever you do
whenever a sign comes to them from the
lord they turn away from it
they have indeed rejected the truth when
it came to them so they will soon face
the consequences of their ridicule
and by the way i just want to claire
brown says that this is not pointing at
mike tyson this is a verse for us to
reflect
when allah subhanahu wa is talking about
subhanallah giving
life and death there's going to be
resurrection and they're talking about
the soul etc
subhanallah brothers and sisters wallahi
this is a beautiful verse and
alhamdulillah
praises belong to allah we worship him
alone and we ask people and call people
to worship him alone
and this is the fitzra this is the
fitzra and we make duato a
dua to allah to guide brother mike tyson
to good companions and
inshallah for him to understand and
learn to heed and share
and understand the statements that is
uttering we know and we understand
he may not mean that but it's dangerous
statements
and we ask allah to keep us from brother
sisters till next time assalamu alaykum